each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available okay so today we have uh Vadim
kusov uh visiting the qu group uh he's a
candidate uh for our group Vadim
actually spent this last summer working
with us so many of us know him very well
his research interests uh mainly Focus
around Quantum compiling uh Quantum
circuit synthesis looking at exact and
approximate synthesis of single and
multic Cubit Gates into different uh
bases of gates and that's what he's
going to talk about today uh he's
getting his uh PhD with uh Michel mosa
at The Institute for quantum Computing
at the University of waterl in Canada
and he'll be finishing up in the spring
um probably March uh so today viim is
going to talk to us about his number
theoretic methods uh number theoretic
methods in Quantum compiling uh and work
he's done on a variety of different
bases uh for single Cubit circuit
decomposition so adem y thank you for
introduction
um so yeah first I start actually was uh
just some broad statement of the problem
so what is uh compiling for quantum
computers and why actually do we need it
uh so on one side we have a Quantum
algorithm uh that we that promise us to
uh solve certain problems much more
efficient than in a classical computer
and uh examples of this is a billion
hidden subgroup problem or chemistry
simulation or very famous factoring
right and on the other hand uh we have a
Quantum Hardware so this is
uh actually uh where we're going to
execute our algorithm and uh it turns
out that uh this enough path it's not
that short from going from high level
description of quantum algorithm uh to a
Quantum hardware and if one day somebody
comes and ask okay I buil this uh some
early model of quantum computer I have
this many Cubit and it um Can execute
this long uh sequences so can I do
something interesting on it and
basically it turns out that this to
answer this question to help
experimentalist to execute uh to to use
his actually computer for something
interesting uh a lot of work uh needs to
be done and I'm going to uh talk about
some problems
uh appearing in this direction today and
here is also just uh example of um that
actually this moment can be uh not that
far of the future this is a slide from
David D vinchenzo talk on qip
2013 basically showing that there is a
some kind of more law um for coherence
time of super conducting Cubit and
basically shows that it's the advance
the advances over the last years is U
pretty
impressive right so I start with an uh
some examples of architectures of
quantum computers uh so we always start
with a uh physical system uh that is uh
uh somehow controlled right and after
control level uh there are several
possibilities depending on uh What uh
physical system we have so the most uh
kind of conventional situation is after
Quantum control we we get a physical
layer gate set and we use this gate set
to execute some full tolerant protocol
uh
to uh improve the quality of the gate
set so it can handle Precision required
for the algorithm and um the most common
example of full tolerant gate set is U
cord plus T I'll explain what it is on
the next slide and uh after that uh we
basically execute circuits in this gate
set and uh the quantum algorithms must
be decomposed into the circuits uh
precisely in this gate set so this is
what actually uh make this path not
trivial right because surface Quantum
algorithm and we need to go like through
many layers to actually uh to to control
in some physical system uh the other uh
two architectures is U related to
topological quantum computer so this
architecture related to ising Anon model
uh so here we get some physically
protected Gates uh Clifford Group which
is uh not enough to get a universal
computation that uh that's why we need
some extra procedures to get a t gate uh
to get universality and this is done for
State distillation uh and the thir uh
picture shows um architecture where all
gate where the gate set available is
actually Universal and topologically
protected and this corresponds to
Fibonacci anion
model and I'll I'll talk today about uh
uh this Gat sets uh Gat set in Fibonacci
anion model and Clifford
um so more now just some example right
so the very common building block on
many Quantum algorithm is quantum Foria
transform and it uses RZ rotations uh
which is this diagonal unitary matrices
right and uh here is example here's a
specific uh matrices of cliford and T
gate say on single Cubit you see this is
a t gate which has a root of unity in it
and Hadar gate and um I also include
other cliford Gates like phase gate and
poly Gates uh ZX um into Gat Set uh for
uh Fibonacci model uh single Cubit gate
set um uh looks like uh up to Global
phase it's 10 root of unity to the 7th
power and uh uh this is the one
generator of a gate set and the other
generator uh is U the first one
conjugated by F Matrix uh which uh is
made of uh inverse of gold golden ratio
and uh its square roots so and I'm in my
talk today I'm actually going to uh
focus on this problem so how you take uh
single Cubit RZ rotations and uh
decompose this into these gate sets and
what's important to mention that this
canot like nearly always this cannot be
done exactly there before you need to
approximate right and the main parameter
of interest is the Precision of
approximation and the efficiency of how
you efficiently solve the problem is
actually uh how many gates you need to
approximate uh this rotation depending
on the Precision you
require okay so now I'm uh um give some
brief overview what it was known before
on this problem uh it's uh
so this problem uh you know was the
question was asked in the beginning of
uh like nearly in the beginning of
research in Quantum Computing and uh uh
first kind of really satisfactory answer
was the slov Ty serum and corresponding
algorithm uh so the uh this um algorithm
itself and appeared like in uh by K so
there was like actually it was
discovered in parallel by Sol and K in
1995 and
1997 and 2005 points out to doon's paper
which makes it's kind of it's kind of a
review with um which is more easy to
actually program on a computer because
uh that work is you know more
theoretical uh and not that
straightforward to
implement um so and uh this question
basically solved uh at least some high
level problem saying that okay if you
have some G set we can do this
efficiently so uh this logarithm says
that uh because we we won't like lose
any speed UPS if you even have a
polinomial speed up in our Quantum
algorithm like grow search or some other
examples right we still uh will have
this speed up because this is just
logarithmic overhead right and uh of
course there was like uh always was a
solution like Brute Force solution uh
here I point out just to papers that
first time actually did it uh for
Clifford and G set Austin Fuller uh so
and you see that number of gates uh you
can uh kind of do with Brute Force
scales like log one over so while in
Slovak Ty it's like log
3.97 so conceptually you know when you
talk about complexity of algorithms it's
not a big deal but once you uh really
helping your experimentalist to do
something interesting it's it becomes a
big deal because uh this uh gives like
big constant factors uh or just big big
uh factors of
overhead uh so there was some other
works um related to this uh which
actually has pretty interesting scaling
but has the drawbacks for example phas
Kickback uh described in K's book uh it
um uh uses like add as a building block
and um kind of has
uh gives you log one over Epsilon
approximation but it use U some number
of ancillas that will scale over time
and um will scale like depending on the
Precision uh so there is like program
ancill rotations by Cod Jones that um
also includes some lot of uh kind of
kind of hierarchical construction with
measurements um
so it heavily depends as a last one on
resource stas and actually you of
complexity HIDs into resource stas is
not Ral to implement and there's also a
work by Chris and um dougas
uh sansy uh on some kind of very
interesting approach how you make a lad
of uh State uh letterers with
measurements and feedback uh to to get
something like 1 Point 12 or a little
bit more right and
um so but still um I think um you know
like classical solution is Slovak Ty
algorithm and uh it's U you know
interesting thing about it you know it
doesn't require measurements and uh
achieves um uh this without any kind of
resource state
so uh question the classical runtime in
case of the face Kickback method and the
p is that for the uh preparation of the
resource State because once you have
that there's no compilation really to be
yeah so actually I mean it's uh why I'm
saying L one ORS I mean there always
runtime classical just to write down a
circuit right so it cannot I mean if you
need to write down circuit right you
will have uh at least this so at least
number of gates in the circuit right and
uh for part actually this is uh some
kind of um you know letter of uh this
classical feedback so those are like
some expectation so this expectation is
does not include resource state right so
and on average you can kind of finish
this letter in constant number of steps
but of course to kind of do compilation
and some classical processing and run
this uh you know classical feedback and
take into account which actual States
you need uh you will still have class
need classical run time I think you can
do it with l really just errors in that
case together
errors with face K back it's erors with
part it's slightly differing right um
yeah okay well and I think what is
actually interesting about this problem
there's like some uh other side of this
problem which uh was has also
interesting interest interesting history
uh so we can ask a question okay uh is
there like how many this Universal gate
sets uh that will actually saturate this
bound so we we've saw like we've seen
like from brute force that clifor and T
can do it right but there is actually no
proof that uh there was no proof that uh
you know Clifford and T saturat lower
bound right and in 1986 and
1987 uh there was paper by luosi Philip
and CERN actually showing that there is
a gat set just example of Gat set which
uh saturates this uh lower bound
right later there was a paper by Aram
hero re and Chan generalizing this
result on S basically so in su2
corresponds to one cubit right and S uh
can corresponds to is CIT is to several
Cubit right and uh just you know very
recently uh there was two results um by
mathematicians actually uh saying that
if you have
any universal Gat Set uh with uh
unitaries that has entries as algebraic
numbers you can you will always saturate
this lower bound and this is not not
non-trivial result so the for2 it was in
2008 for sud it was in 2011 and uh the
first author actually is the field
medalist so and uh for example second
paper is like around like 60 Pages proof
um
right so um this kind of shows that I
mean actually questions that I'm
answering are not trivial because uh
even like existential like results about
existence are difficult and I'm talking
here about constructive uh constructive
proofs for some interesting special
cases of this problem so this is just
you know some uh kind of um additional
motivation to see okay how it works
right so this are results for Fibonacci
anons right this um for example this is
uh what we need to achieve Precision 10
to minus 10 with Sol algorithm and this
is for number sertic method so like one
160 or over like 4,000 and if you go
like up to higher precisions like 10 to
minus 30 which is also pretty
conceivable with what might be required
for Quantum algorithm uh it's 458 Gates
versus like 5 to 10 to the 5 so this is
why I'm saying that uh once you actually
experimentalist come to you and ask for
help then using methods like slowy Tye
is not the uh not the way to go you
actually need something much
better okay so now I'm um yeah maybe one
comment I want to make um also as I'm
talking about Fibonacci anion so this is
actually the other thing uh you see here
is I mentioned this all for cliford d t
right and it turns out actually the phe
kickback is based on the adder right
which is easy to do in case of Clifford
t g set but totally non easy to do in
Fibonacci case actually um basically to
do an add to be able to do an add you
need some methods like this so uh I
think like for Fibonacci case actually
num sertic method are kind of much more
important and much more special because
to go like to be able to do most of
these methods you actually need to do
them first uh need to do to get um uh
for example c not right and to gate and
to to get this gat you in Fibonacci
model you need number theoretic
approximations okay so with this now I'm
uh first I will U talk about how this
works for clifor and gate
set um it's U kind of old the result and
a little bit bit more uh you know U
there's most things known and you you
can be uh here like really really really
precise uh so this is how it's done
before right so you start with some
unitary and as a result of your
approximation you get circuit for
example from Sol algorithm and the way
how it's done with number theoretic
methods uh you take a unitary you do a
round unitary roundoff and you come up
with exact unitary which is uh close to
your original unitary and exact by exact
unitary I mean the unit that can be done
exactly uh with the gate thre of your
choice in this case cliford TT later it
will will be G set for Fibonacci anion
and then you apply exact synthesis
algorithm to get a cliford plus T
circuit or um circuit for Z gate set and
um so what's important here uh right
it's actually uh not just to uh be able
to do this roundoff procedure and exact
synthesis you also want to control the
uh kind of quality of your
approximation and uh uh
because as we've seen from this bound
right so the more gates so the better
quality you want more gates you need
right and there is a question how you
take this into account this right so
actually um other important part of this
exact this story is that you you're able
to say okay
so how this unit
must look like if you want more gaze and
how it must look like if you want less
gaze and you make this Choice during
round of procedure so during round of
procedure you can actually make a choice
how much Freedom you you get right so
this corresponds how long circuit you
will end in the end and and based on
this you you get a better round off or
slightly worse dependent on the chice
let me so so so your error tolerance is
set in that first step
here but you need to be able to somehow
propagate it into the synthesized
circuit at the right um so uh so this
how this happens right so uh basically
there's um and know um you say okay I
have circuits of a certain lens right
and this says that this exact unit must
have a certain form right once you have
this certain form that uh cannot so this
form kind of fix the lens of the circuit
so you won't get more than something
right and once you fix this lens you get
some Freedom right and the more lens uh
kind of more more lensy circuit you get
more freedom you propagate on this step
and more freedom you have you get better
approximations so this is how it works
well and U yeah for this part what for
this particular case uh in this actually
case story about how the exact exact
unit this looks like is pretty simple uh
right so all unitaries that can be done
exactly with single Cubit must have
entries of this form right so it's um
sum of uh different powers of a root of
unity with integer coefficients divided
by power of square root of two and so if
each entry of your single Cubit looks
like this then you can come up with a
circuit and I I will show in a few
slides actually the intuition how this
power here is related uh to the
complexity of the circuit this is what
I'm going to
talk um yeah here is reminder how the
Gat Gat set looks like right so we see
that uh in this case entries are of the
desired form right so you have this
power square root of two once and this
is H root of unity so they have desired
form um this uh set it's a ring so it's
closed on the addition and
multiplication so when we mult multiply
these matrices together we get again
unit from the same ring and this U gives
this uh serum that I announced already
so single Cubit unitary can be
implemented exactly if and only if uh
its entries has this form right and the
other part of the uh theorum is interest
is efficient algorithm how to actually
get a circuit out of it and it's both
efficient and it's also guarantees
Optimum in the number of hardart and
Gates right so the only Gates that you
kind of um have freedom is some some
small amount of Po so all other things
are optimal except like we don't make
statements about optimality of poly
Gates which are like really really cheap
in uh full tolerance
setting okay here is some examples just
to show intuition behind how this uh
Power of the denominator uh related to
the uh circuit size so I take just HT to
the N which is um has infinite order
right and I raise it to different powers
and I see I look actually instead of
entries I look at absolute value square
square of entries and we see that after
each step basically kind of if you pull
out uh this um denominator uh Power
increases by one right and um so this
motivates uh the definition what's
called like smaller denominator exponent
uh which is the smallest exponent you
can get here because why why is this
like word is smallest here right because
there is some kind of Freedom we can
multiply this for example by square otk
and this Square ot2 by square root and
write five right so basically smallest
means that we minimize this by keeping
this still integers or integer like what
keeping them of this form right with
integer
coefficients right and now I'm going to
make precise uh the intuition uh so uh
this is
um uh basically main kind of uh uh main
important result right so uh we want to
know if you want to simplify circuit
right we kind of wants to uh chop some
like its complexity uh by small steps
right and for this we use uh generators
of the form HT to the key right so we
going of use them to uh reduce
U kind of unwind the whole the circuit
for the unitary right and um the
important question what happens to this
denominator when we do this right and uh
this statement basically shows uh that
by adjusting K here right we can uh
adjust uh this power of denominator
either it increases by one e decreasing
by one I leave it the same right and
this is kind of a basic thing for
efficiency of all algorithm so we can
always this means we can always decrease
this SD right and basically we can
greedily uh reduce SD for the circuit uh
and
uh kind of get some very simple unit in
the end right uh so this is more precise
statement of the algorithm right so on
each we take input unitary we uh
calculate smaller smallest denominator
exponent then we calate new unitary with
different powers of K here right and um
pick K such a way that we can represent
it in this form so you see n minus one
is crucial here we have n and we can
always reduce it by one right and then
we replace our kind of reminder
unitary uh with this uh new one and also
we kind of keep in memory what the k
what what K we use for the choice to
reconstruct the circuit and we can do
this up to So like um
so um I will discuss later there was
some progress on this part uh this is
the way uh so the in the first version
just was can reduce it below four and
for below four this is very small amount
of different unitaries uh that you can
look
up uh in your
database right uh here are some ideas
why is actually H optimal and why why is
T optimal so I start with h op imity and
it turns out that one can show that to
increase or decrease the small
denominator exponent by one you need
precisely one I G right and then you
check that the set of unitaries with
smaller denominator exponent four is the
same as a set of unit with u that needs
to be needs uh 300 Mar gate right and
basically this is uh then shown using
results that i' I've shown you before so
this is a crucial step to show um H
optimality right and for T optimality
it's actually follows from H optimality
uh and it turns out if you have U
Circuit of this form on like have I in
the end in the beginning uh then this
circuit must be also a t optimal right
and um this is the first step and on the
Second Step you actually of um stack
this outside two things right and pick
KJ in in such a way uh and of then
uh uh number of uh so basically make
sure that number of other marks is
optimal by for this Circuit by picking K
andj and then you can understand what's
was kind of uh on the ends right and out
of this you get a precise expression for
calculating a number of
TGs uh for the unit for the given unit
so
and it's it's actually I mean it's kind
of very precise very efficient
expression right because you don't need
to know much you just need to know this
one over square < tk2 right and uh some
residues um of the entries so I have a
small question here so when uh since
since you reduce the circuit using h t
to the power K right yes uh so so do
you count in the
the occurrences of the phase gate so T
the power K could have or zero uh yeah
it turns out that you can um there are
just um so not all um so first um as you
get like uh H optimal circuit you cannot
have HP H phase gate H because this is
not H optimal because you can do the
same circuit with one H gate um then
it's a kind of eliminate some
possibilities and you get just two
possibilities with u t gate um and one
of them is a just T gate and the other
one can be expressed as uh tger
multiplied by poly poz Matrix right so
you actually you don't need phase gate
in these steps you just need po Z that's
why I said that I don't and I count yeah
I count the T dagger the same cost as
the Tate which is uh motivated by full
tolerance in partial right because in
full tolerance is absolutely the same
cost to do like T
andt okay yeah but thanks yeah so and
this is just some kind of a little bit
more details on how this proved right
and so there actually like one analytic
part of the proof to show this
inequality so this this is done just
through like T series of exercises about
the properties of this uh smaller
denominator exponents so you try to
understand how it behaves on the
addition and
multiplication and the second part is
actually when you need to show that you
can always pick the K uh such it can be
increased and reduced by one right and
this is um computer assisted part that
just need to check some finite number of
cases um and here is kind of just one
idea is crucial right uh so once you
have numbers like this right you don't
need to know the whole number to
understand if the SD can be reduced or
not you just need to do need to know
basically three last bits and computer
assist part just take different
combination of last bits and checks
exhaustively for the different
combinations that this can be done uh so
yeah uh this is how yeah I'll discuss
later that there are some kind of maybe
easier way uh to look at this but um I
think uh
there's still benefits of this way
because you will see that there's some
kind of similarities and differences for
Fibonacci case uh which still look u in
some in some sense similar um right uh
so and actually exact synthesis
algorithm give you like a tool uh to
efficiently approximate uh circuits and
it it it can be used in different ways
and here I want to
highlight um just one of this uh one of
ways and this is um kind of some smart
search method right so this is actually
about U if you want to really guarantee
the quality so how you find Optimal uh
circuits so it's it's not like it's not
done in polinomial time but you can do
it to the precisions like 10 to - 15 10
to - 17 which is uh maybe which is quite
sufficient for many
applications uh and um especially for
early ones and then I will also like
later mention why it's can actually can
be like sufficient for for anything at
all right uh so my aim to approximate
this RZ rotation right and I'm
approximated with unit like this one all
entries is from the re that I I've been
talking about uh the distances I'm
interested in is a tracing uh Global pH
in variant Trace distance um all right
and it can be simplified to expression
like this and important uh Point here is
that this Expressions depends only on
the one entry of the unitary right and U
this U gives of uh way um this dictates
the way how approximation works I just
first I uh pick x uh in such a way that
I achieve certain approximation and then
I reconstruct the full unitary and to
reconstruct the full unitary um the
equation like this must be solved and
the main kind of challenge of this
method is that this equation does not
always have a solution and the finding
solution to this equation is also a
challenge um so this is just U actually
just kind of plot this is a complex
plane right and this are different
choices of X and uh it's R if uh
solution exists and blue if it doesn't
right and um so this is uh of course uh
if you consider all possible numbers of
this form they will like just you know
uh your plane will be just colored
completely but this is a drawing that
limits the denominator exponent so and
this is what we do in the algorithm
right we uh this is the way how we
adjust the quality um we first pick uh
based on Precision we want we
choose maximal denominator exponents
that we will use and once it is
chosen uh uh we look on possible entries
with uh this uh denominator exponent and
um solve our algorithm so and this
basically solving this equation leads to
the problem that is called relative Norm
equation um
umin particular picture has been um I
think
four um yeah and this is just a part of
complex plane you see it
zoomed that's a plot of X and Y it's
real and imaginary part real imaginary
part of what of x
x um yeah and uh just uh to give a brief
feeling basically how to solve this
equation you actually need U one of the
sub problems is the factoring uh and
it's known to be a hard problem but it
turns out that uh actually in this case
it's kind of in that regime you know
there was a lot of work on factoring
right and actually here we can harness
all this uh nice uh number Ser results
on factoring on horis sixs for factoring
uh and actually you you need roughly to
factor numbers up to 256 bits and this
can be done very easily on Modern
computers because of that you know
a well so it's actually like on on on on
the usual computer
right um yeah and
uh uh so and how the algorithms works it
actually uh kind of I'm I phrase the
problem of finding this approximation in
slightly different way I I it's a
problem with a promise so I say okay I I
promise there is exist approximation uh
with some Precision um Epson and I want
to find something better uh with given
complexity why it's kind of why it's
okay to consider this problem with the
promise because you know if you do your
search iteratively right for example you
find like best circuit for 50 Gates
right and then you know what's the best
circuit for 50 Gates and what's the
Precision gives right so if you want to
find the next one that uses like 51 or
52 you you don't you are not more
interested in some quality that lower
that you have already achieved right so
this this is a way how where you can
take this promise from
right and um this uh basically limits
that kind of possibilities that you need
to consider uh to very small region just
um right and
um uh it's also the problem is sp to
like real part and imaginary part um and
um uh basically you uh choose possible
approximations for real and imaginary
part and then check if there is solution
or not so basically um you do this um uh
factoring and check necessary conditions
uh for the existence of
solution right and here is just maybe to
point out to the other like subtlety in
this problem uh which I call is related
to what they call minimal unitaries so
the quality of approximation depends
only on the uh X entry right but the t
count is actually depends on the whole
unitary and uh you interested in what's
the so as y the choice of Y is arbitary
right so you're actually interested in
the uh what kind of minimal to count you
can get for x and for this you need to
consider all solutions to Norm equation
so basically to guarantee the minimality
algorithm you need to go like uh through
all solutions to this
equation and uh minimize this t count
overall Solutions I'll skip example
because I'm a little bit short on time
uh so this is uh just um basically shows
the work that was done on this right so
this is uh paper on exact synthesis uh
this is generalization of exact
synthesis by gal and C to multibit case
uh so the next work is the first U
published result which saturated lower
Bond using a fixed number of ancillas
and no resource States uh then it was
improved by cellers by eliminated
ancillas from it right and uh this was
in probabilistic polinomial time right
and this is an improvement by around 30%
um over this um by kind of investing
more computational
resources uh and U this is a kind of
preliminary work of what I'm was just
talking now because now actually I can
prove optimality which wasn't POS wasn't
done in this work okay and now I'm
moving to Fibonacci ANS and uh topology
IAL quantum computer just to remind
actually why it's so exciting uh uh to
work u in topological models it's kind
of this way you get U Hardware level
full tolerance so your computer you get
a gate set that is universal and
protected just by design of your
physical system um this is uh so you
don't need some like extra things like
full tolerant protocols or magic State
distillation protocols uh to achieve
universality and well there's
once you know once there is a hope that
you don't need extra things that there
is a hope that you okay you can do more
computation right uh uh but it turns out
that actually like the whole possibility
of this model depends on how well you
compile right and um this is why so this
a gate set that you get in this model
right so it includes um um yeah 10 root
of unity and inverse of golden fraction
and what's important
like what's kind of you know the way you
pay for this universality right so you
cannot Implement exactly even a bit flip
so which is uh you know pretty set and
if you use SOL typ algorithm for that so
will just eliminate all these advantages
uh of using this model without like
State distillation or running extra full
tolerant protocols so and um here is
some as I told before also you need the
single Cubit synthesis method not just
for flips but to actually come up with
good multibit Gates Right For example
this are examples for that U of coming
how you can come up with c not and this
is you see this is how computation like
visualized in this model right and uh
this a Precision that you still Achi can
achieve it's um pretty small and if you
go uh to larger precisions with Sol Ty
you won't be able to draw it right and
so this is generic theme how in this
case this masses work and this is a work
that I I done like during my internship
in the summer with u Alex bov and Chris
War right and this is high level you see
uh it's uh again we start from unry we
do a round off to exact unitaries right
and then apply exact synthesis to get ft
circuit I'll will explain in a minute
what it is and here's some extra step
which is uh
optimization uh to actually uh bring it
to Sigma 1 Sigma 2 circuit which is uh
so Sigma 1 Sigma 2 circuit corresponds
to actually the SC that you're actually
doing the mo so in Fibonacci model your
moving particles around right and sigma
1 and sigma 2 corresponds to the uh
particle moves right while this gate set
is just convenient for my theoretical
purposes and it's not so directly
related to how complex your you know
computation will
be um okay uh so this is uh definition
of this ft gate set so it's somehow
looks similar to TG that we have before
but with st root of unity uh instead of
a root of unity and this is uh F gate um
which is looks the same like as F Matrix
for Fibonacci model but it's actually a
gate that can be executed using some
sequence of Sigma 1 Sigma 2 you can just
search so this can be found uh and it's
in our paper right uh so and here the
story is more interesting about exact
synthesis in the sense that how exact
exactly synthesizable unit looks like
right so it actually has some like
additional SC the square root of t uh
that um so UV and V dagger UD dagger are
from uh have this form right so this is
integers extended by 10 root of
unity right and this Square Ro to it
just kind of you know sits around and
just uh plays role when we calculate
things but it's kind of U just um symol
and all all kind of variations that all
our freedoms are related to uh this UV
what rings of integers so this is also
like there's one feature interesting
that um you have the square root of to
and the other feature that is
interesting that you have actually work
with ring of integers instead of Ring of
integers divided by some square roots to
some power right so this is and actually
this is changes the structure of exact
synthesis proof a lot because you don't
have any more this like square roots
powers that you that was used before to
kind of understand the circuit
complexity so here we need something
different uh to understand
complexity Omega is the same as Z 10
right and you you're kind of use it
interchangeably oh
okay yeah sorry uh yeah I you know it's
uh typo right so yeah Omega here is 10
10 root of unity yeah it's so yeah could
be confusing in this
example
um um so and uh you know
uh well actually you know the other
important object that we can consider
the real subin uh is z to and uh for
example absolute value squared you
remember like in Clifford TV also looked
at abs well squ and this is belongs to
this R of wiers and the next important
object U is G automorphism of uh This
Ring of integers and it moves this tow
which is inverse of golden fracture to
minus uh five which is um golden golden
ratio right and um so there are
different choices actually of complexity
measure just in our papers there is a
different one but uh here just kind of
to explain it more quickly uh so kind of
um it just you I think it a busy a bit
easier to explain with this one uh so
this is a g conjugation of absolute
value squared of the
entry right and
um um again some slide to show the
intuition behind it right so we uh look
at unitaries of this form and we rise it
to uh to power n and see what happens to
complexity measure and we see that it's
kind of becomes larger and larger right
and we are going to use this intuition
for exact synthesis so
um here's exact synthesis algorithm we
take as input exactly synthesizable
unitary so the unitary of this form
right and while value of complexity
measure is greater than one we use f
multiplied by t uh to the m to reduce
the complexity right and um basically we
pick M so that complexity measure of the
result is minimal possible and The
crucial here is that it can always be
done and in the end we can achieve mu
equals to one and once we achieve this
it's just very simple situation just
some power of root of unity um which we
can handle right and so this is um small
just
very briefly showing the idea of the
proof uh right
so this is uh what you get after you
multi so this is the entry after
multiplication entry of the unit after
you multiply it by ft to the K right and
this is before and we are interested in
this ratio how it changes right um so
and basically what's important that we
can always make this ratio uh roughly
less than one3 on each step and this
means that uh the number of steps is
logarithmic in the uh value of
complexity
measure right and how this is achieved
this is roughly uh basically you can
Define two vectors two unit vectors on a
complex plane and by CH choosing K uh
youjust the angle between these two
vectors and uh rotation basically
rotations that you have are rotations by
five pi over 5 and by adjusting this
rotation you can kind of move with as
ortogonal as possible and why and
because of this you can uh go below this
number
okay yeah maybe um so I mentioned before
then uh complexity is also so we need to
have a good you know take of what is
complexity right how we limit the
complexity of our unit so in this case
we actually limit uh complexity by the
value of uh by the logarithm of the
complexity measure so how complex our
unitary is pro proportional to the
logarithm of complexity measure it's
it's kind of similar but uh to what we
have in cliford TT case right in that
case we have this square root in the Su
power right and the power which is
related to logarithm uh Power of the
square root was a complexity
measure uh okay and U to handle General
single Cubit um synthesis problem uh
there are two sub problems right first
one is the RZ rotations and the second
one RZ followed by X so important case
when 5 Z is xgate right so this includes
actually how to synthesize xgate and um
uh there is a lamb in our
paper proved by Alex uh showing that uh
you can e represent unitary and as
product of three RZ rotations either you
have this uh the other case right and
now I'm going to concentrate on our
rotations and in this part actually I'm
talking about polinomial time
algorithm uh instead of
uh as opposed to the last uh for
Clifford T case where I I was talking
about something that is guarantees
optimality and uh here is actually
reason for that because um complexity
measure in this case is so it allows you
to synthesize unitaries but it doesn't
allow you to rof the complexity just
straight right so in that case we just
looking by unit we say oh this many this
many hadamar gaze is needed and uh
number of T Gaz is plus minus one from
the number of hadamar and in this case
we cannot do these things um yet maybe
we'll be able to do them in the future
so and uh here I'm talking about if
polinomial time
algorithm um but constant will be pretty
good as it'll show later so this is
again the distance that we are aiming
for this is the same distance right and
it's again simplifies to this expression
right and constraint in this case looks
slightly
different and before we had just um the
same thing without Tow and here we got
extra Tow and now this are just integers
like integers extended by a 10 root of
unity right and again we kind of start
uh with actually since uh that um gives
us required Precision so we identif so
this gray region uh here corresponds to
uh things that have gives us Precision
of approximation Epson right and then we
uh sample uh U from here uh is actually
simpler to sample from this um uh green
region so the sample U from here such
that uh we have some predefined
complexity measure like bounded
complexity measure and this m here is
basically how we bound it so we compute
M which is around like log to one/
Epsilon U with some uh constants and uh
uh we rescale also we rescale aises
right and this rescaling is done
actually to improve constant factors uh
because uh once you do
roundoff um
you you actually kind of this way you
kind of utilize the bits more
efficiently because you have a choice
you might not rescale this but then you
won't utilize the kind of all your
degrees of freedom as efficiently as you
could right um so for polinomial time in
we actually um concentrate on a special
case of constraints that are easy to
handle and easy to solve this because I
mentioned that we have as a sub problem
we have a factor in right and everybody
knows that this a hard problem right so
how we come up with polinomial time
algorithm when the sub problem is
factoring and it turns out that we can
aim for easy cases right so I give just
one example of easy case you can there
you can come up with other examples of
easy cases right but this is just one uh
with when uh this right hand side of the
norm equation looks like five to some uh
integer multiplied by prime number of
this form right and U this basically
prime number of these forms is uh form
of prime numbers that must be here is uh
related U to number theoretic structure
of the problem it's related to which
prime which primes are completely split
in the uh 10 degree uh in the catomic
field uh 10 degree catomic
field right and this condition is uh
also
necessary uh it basically say say uh
kind of follows directly from uh
positivity of absolute value squared and
the second one follows from the fact
that that automorphism that we were
using for G G automorphism that we were
using for complexity measure it can be
actually defined also on the Ring of for
the T root of unity and you can
propagate it inside right so if you have
um a plus bet to uh here then and it's
solvable the second thing when we kind
of apply this Gala Auto refus on top
also must be solvable right so we and it
turns out there is a simple well not
simple but um
efficient um algorithm for solving Norm
equation in this
case right and um this is example of how
the sampling is going going right is
well that that picture is kind of a
little bit not realistic it's not how it
happens because Epsilon so small when
kind of for interesting cases so it's
kind of more closer to
reality right and uh basically divide
that great uh green region uh into this
um cells right and uh number of cells um
uh scales like one over Epsilon right so
basically um
smaller um yeah smaller Epsilon we get
more cells we get uh and uh we randomly
sample from them and sometimes
uh we get nonsolvable cases and
sometimes we get solvable but not easily
solvable and
uh sometimes you get solvable cases and
so this what's actually uh this is
somehow analogous to prime numbers
theorem right and uh in Prime numers
theorem says that if you sample from uh
numbers from zero to M uh you will uh
the density of primes will be M over log
M so basically number of efforts because
you need to do before you successfully
find the prime in this random process is
log um log M so that's why and similar
thing happens here it basically actually
some kind of um conjecture because uh
that this happens here it's uh that we
rely on our proof uh and this means that
we can efficiently find easy so we can
find easy case in like with with
logarithmic number of efforts that
guarantees efficiency of algorithm the
other thing that guarantees the
efficiency of the algorithm is that
actually primes can be recognized in
like polinomial times so there is a
famous result the Reon that uh you know
there's like deterministic algorithm for
uh checking if the prime is not or or it
is right uh and or some earlier results
like primality test like Miller Rabin
primality test
that we use
here
so test has a
certain false positive right it's small
but
it's so the deterministic one does it
still have false positive no that's so
there was like very I mean I think
within last decade right this was
breakthroughs so nailing down the
problem of prime testing right that you
can in polinomial time decide the if the
number is prime is not without any false
positive it's like AKs
algorithm
what just
100ce yeah I mean so M Rabin is better
for practice yes because that one is has
pretty bad uh constants and
uh and pretty bad actually powers in the
logarithm so yeah
that's okay yeah and uh yeah this is
just one other small detail how it uh
basically how you pick um points inside
the cells right to actually pick the
point uh we use uh continued fractions
right so we um first we uh select the
take a center of the cell uh then we
find um uh imaginary coordinate just by
finding the best possible approximation
with a contined fraction right and then
we do the same thing for x coordinate
right and U so this is kind of
technically how how the results looks
like uh so this is what you can achieve
um so basically with roughly like to to
the N right uh
Precision uh by allowing uh B to be less
than five to and and here you can see
actually where is it bit balancing uh
thing comes from right because if you
don't
rescale the whole thing right then U
basically X will be around one right and
um uh B fixed and a will be kind of too
for a the too small degree of Freedom
right so by rescaling actually you kind
of take into account the degrees of
freedom for a that we have oh this is
very high level so uh if it's confusing
uh don't worry
um okay so and this are experimental
results of how this U algorithm for
Fibonacci anion works right so it was
implemented in C++ uh using par GPS sub
routine to solve Norm equation uh and
this is a comparison to Brute Force
search so this is actually more like uh
about you know how good so I've been
talking you know about that algorithm
efficient and it uh as efficient an
asymptotic sense right but okay what's
the constant factors uh yeah and this
shows what the constant factors so uh
this is um what our algorithm does and
this is what uh results of Brute Force
right so you see that it's uh uh around
basically like 20% overhead in
comparison to Brute Force which is uh I
think very good for uh polinomial time
algorithm right and uh so this is the
case of RZ rotations and for rzx um is a
slightly larger
overhead okay this is
um this shows how it scales right and
this are there are different parts right
so synthesis part this is exact
synthesis algorithm Norm equations this
is part this is inside par GP uh just
you know uh because it's it's not very
well documented so we actually needed to
check if it's actually really does
uh solve things in polinomial time uh
and uh this is as part of approximation
algorithm right and uh the last thing is
there is synthesis uh so I didn't talk
before much about it all right so this
is uh the thing uh this is how you
translate your f t circuit into Sigma 1
Sigma 2 circuit which is needed uh to
really execute the things on the
hardware and uh here I use pip hole
optimization so I made a database of
optimal Sigma 1 Sigma 2 circuit up to
some size right and uh then I take a
circuit ft circuit uh rewrite it us a
simple so you can express F gate using
Sigma 1 Sigma 2 and you can express that
my T gate well for this T gate for this
model right uh precisely using small
number of generators you get the
sequence and then you optimize it
uh using pip hole optimization so you uh
take subcircuit and uh find the unitor
in the database replace with the optimal
one and do it until uh it's possible to
do the compression um I would I would
say it's like around twice something
like that I think maybe yeah think
my okay it was around twice I yeah
probably should kind of do this
experiment uh to show um
um how how it you know some because I
just did some you know on the way of my
development um looked at
this yeah and um yeah and it's important
to know that this scaling is actually uh
in all these algorithms this is U kind
of typical to present scaling as the
number of arithmetic operation as
opposed to number of bit size in the bit
size right so this is the scaling is the
number of arithmetic
operation uh because I'm using fixed uh
bit size types so I use large ones uh
but it's a fixed size so there for
example 5 12 uh bits integers 1,24 bits
integers and
248 size integers and this is this shows
uh scaling of algorithm run time
depending on the choice of how many BS
you use right and the last point I think
to make about this that you see the
scaling is like all below like two right
and for Slovakia type it's like 270
something right so I mean this algorithm
not just gives much better results it's
typ it's actually runtime scales better
so you know it's uh
basically Vince on the all kind of on in
the all
directions right yeah this is just um as
a part of the conclusion just want to
highlight a few other uh things that
I've done on um related to compiling so
uh this work is called like synthesis of
unit with CER circus it's a Improvement
of exact synthesis algorithm for multi
Cubit unitaries for multi Cubit CER
unitaries so the results that I was I
mentioned before by Salinger it had
actually with a number of cubits the
circuit size scale double exponentially
right and uh here it just scales
exponentially and uh well and of course
you can come up with cubits uh with
circuits that actually has exponential
number of gates uh with a number of
Cubit so it's kind of you know basically
you cannot I think cannot do much better
uh in a sympotic sense for generic
situation right because sure you can do
for for special cases you can do better
than exponent and uh but this kind of
small small papers that close this kind
of theoretical question about exact
synthesis right so in this paper it's um
algorithm for t count this is more you
know like kind of practical paper like
um about uh for maybe two and three
cubits uh for clier T um can you
actually how how you improve your ex
exhaustive search and what was done here
basically kind of split Clifford group
from t count
and come up with this comp with a
canonical form that kind of remove this
uh you know make it invariant with
respect to cliford group and um uh this
allows you kind of to in once you're
using some like exhaustive methods this
allows you
significantly compressed search space
and as a consequence you were able for
example to prove that uh if you're not
using measurements and ancillas you need
uh 70 gates to make a to gate so this
was the paper that first rigorously
proved this result of course I mean this
is you know it's kind of a little bit
this particular result is you know I
mean it's a little bit of theoretical
interest more than like practical
because uh there is no like circuits
that use measurement and classical
feedback that can do to like in with 4
GS but uh still you know the technique
uh and ideas I think uh will be useful
uh for optimization of circuits uh
because uh in PIP hole optimization for
example if you the larger dat database
you get the better results you have
right so it's um actually um I did this
kind of experiment for this paper and
I've seen like uh serious difference
between for example when I'm using three
Cubit database to optimize cliford uh
circuit and when I'm using 4 Cubit
database right uh and also this paper
kind of nicely matches this one because
you know kind of we remove this problem
from here right and it studed separately
in this paper so uh how how you can
actually optimize cfer cus and for small
number of cubits uh there is a way using
binary simplec representation uh you can
build U pretty large databases up to
like handling like up to four cubits and
uh also this look to what happens when
you use them for p optimization of lar
things and the last one is kind of think
um paper with Nathan we
right
well it's right say to say paper by Nate
and V by me uh that kind of asking the
question about single Cub synthesis in
slightly different way uh which is very
neat
because um in many cases you're not
really so all the way around here I I
was asking about absolute Precision
right and sometimes you absolute
precision is not the uh probably thing
that uh I mean it's it's can be high
right in many cases you can especially
like in simulation chemistry simulation
you might want to rotate by very small
angle but your PR like relative
Precision is small but absolute
Precision is still big so on this paper
it actually addresses how to benefit in
this from this situation so what you can
actually do you can do measurements and
classical feedback kind of split your uh
rotation in two parts like montisa and
exponent and do exponent part with some
threee
structure and U uh because of this uh
basically we can beat that log one over
like bit lower bounds up to constant
Factor because you can come up with um
uh numeric lower bounds how good you can
doing Clifford andt case right um and
you can actually beat it uh by kind of
stating problem
differently um in this
paper um okay and uh here's my uh
conclusion so uh basically today I
discussed how ideas from computational
numbers Theory can be applied to Circuit
synthesis of single Cubit unitaries uh
right so I showed efficient asymptotic
um asymptotically optimal algorithm for
uh compiling to Fibonacci anion braid
patterns and I showed
uh you know sketched um how you can get
optimal andca free cliford plus T
circuits uh solving the same problem All
Above is implemented in C++ so it's not
you know just not theoretical work is
actually know practical it works and
this uh for CLI Fort is uh it's open
source project um so this was uh I I am
developing here at I was developing in
the summer and also continue
contributing right and um like I want to
finish actually with the question what
is next right and um I think the next
kind of questions that are interesting
to look at is include measurements in
this number theoretic Frameworks um this
is one interesting Direction uh the
other interesting Direction actually
kind of uses method to come up is good
to multic Cubit Fibonacci circuits and
also I still I still think that
something interesting can be done for
multi Cubit Clifford and T circuits once
you use for example two or three Cubit
uh and uh that paper by David goset and
me and others I think it's kind of
starting point can be a starting point
uh and um last question is was the
generic mathematical structure behind
exact synthesis because answering it is
also important because I think uh once
you include this measurements right you
can get access to some other number
fields and um Alex asked me this
question like long time ago how you
combine things right how combine for
example result from their work which is
um uh V basis right uh this for example
Clifford and T actually I should mention
that V basis is precisely the thing that
was in sarak paper when they prove
existential result and then Alex and
Christ and Yuri uh showed uh that you
know there is a constructive way
actually for that gate set right so this
also kind of interesting yeah so thanks
um thanks everybody for intention uh
that's
it
questions yeah I'm I'm curious uh with
your work with Demetri involving uh
Clifford synthesis yeah um have you
noticed any um side effects that or any
improvements that my be relevant for say
randomized benchmarking or other
applications well I think uh so that
kind
of um yeah I did you know I kind of
didn't mention this here yeah as one of
our application we mentioned um
randomized benchmarking right which is
so randomized benchmarking is a uh way
how you kind of check the quality of
it's a modern way of checking quality of
your quantum computer right before there
was like this tomography right but it's
uh difficult to do and not efficient and
randomized benchmarking protocol all
allows you kind of to extract some rough
uh quality information rough information
about the quality of uh how your
computer works and uh basically this um
one of other application for this uh
work of Clifford optimization actually
perform this benchmarking protocols
better so you can uh basically have a
shorter sequences uh to perform the this
experiments faster and you know uh for
example if you compare to what you get
uh using uh some there is like algorithm
for decomposing uh Clifford unit into
circuits by um this kind of canonical
that works in polinomial time but it
gives you some long circuit and uh our
circuit is probably like around um for
small number of cubits can be like uh
maybe two three four times shorter so
this just gives you you know like
reduces your waiting time in physics
experiment and um uh I think that's
might be interesting thing about
relating uh this to this benchmarking
application that uh it's kind of puts
together implementation at pip hole
optimization so first you use opt your
circuit to Benchmark things right and
then you once you get your cliford
circuit you replace precise you optimize
it using the same database so this
ensures that your circuit in your
algorithm is has the same circuit that
you use for benchmarking so and I think
yeah um and yeah I think in that
direction there is also some freedom to
explore because uh you know there are
tradeoffs you can play depending on um
what gates in your physical system are
more difficult to do and easier to do
because in that paper we just looked at
some basic cases and there are like ways
how you can um maybe do a little bit
further this Brute Force part uh
depending on your
architecture
thanks matical question um for this ft
basis so you had certain things like
since you had 10th root of unity I guess
um the the 10th power of one of these
Gates is equal to the identity yes I
guess this F gate squar perhaps is
identity are there any other non-trivial
relations or is it a free other than
that so we've been looking at U you know
so this is you know not published and so
we we've been looking at uh canonical
form for the circuit right and um
basically uh there are so the and
trivial relation is like Z non-trivial
relation is like um uh includes like SE
powers of uh T and uh it's like f t Cub
f t Cube f t Cube I think equals to
Identity if I'm not mistaken right and
there's actually we come up with a
canonical form um for that I'm pretty
sure that it's kind of how it must be
but I don't have a proof of it so you
basically uh cannot have third and seven
Powers so you can have a conical form
like ft ft right and you cannot have
third powers of t uh and seven power and
you cannot have a bit strings like um
one then a bunch of fours and one so be
that's because of that identity actually
because um because of that identity you
can kind of a little bit exchange it
once and force and move them together
and bring it to three which becomes non
optimal so there is younger of
course um so so it's it's a need group
theoretical problem it's the group is
clearly finet
representable but what is the finite
representation in terms of of uh
generators which are the two generators
uh what are the the minimum set of
relations it's not know but those those
no I I I mean so so my point is that um
that uh the last one that ft Cube the
last it's not unrival uh the only
non-trivial one yeah so because um I
what I actually I did like I got this
canonical form I I can so you can uh
solve recur system of recurrence
relations to get how many optimal
circuits you need you have this specific
number of this fges right and I did
computer search and I compare the
numbers and they're the same that's the
only nonrival one or it's it's not
actually ftq Cub
right the consequence of it's it's not
something I'm just asking are there is
it a theorum that there are no
other it's not
pro but I think it's you know I can
believe it
I I believe it but
uh but it's not yet proofed
yet
yeah um and we thought about other so in
the beginning you showed you know these
non-constructive
uh papers and they talk about other
bases you know these algebraic entries
as for su2 and S have you thought about
other bases that might be of interest to
look at yeah I think um cuz you know now
we what we have three yeah I think uh so
I I didn't I didn't think like of any
specific ones but I kind of thought
about the sources like where they can
come from right and uh so they can come
from actually for Fibonacci they can
come from including measurements in the
model right so because each time you
include measurement you will normalize
right so there might be some other
variations of uh like you know in
Fibonacci case and the same thing like
um
so so in your paper analysis it's like
we get so V basis is one example right
and you have like other uh possible
denominators right and uh so this also
comes from you know can uh I think
basically the way to get this as the
basis is is do some this um measurements
uh and and see uh what you get in the uh
once you apply
measurements yeah yeah yeah so this
is
um I've been sort of musing for quite a
while as some of you know in the
audience
about Quantum 4A transform in Radix
other than
two or a power of two
um it's pretty easy to generate
rotations of pi over 10 or pi over 5 or
something like that with this sort of
idea what what is left that
at least is generating a state which
superposes equal amplitudes by 012 3 and
four uh sorry 012 3 and 4 by five if you
could superpose those and then use those
to control application of the rotations
you would have a radex 5 to the k4a
transform so how could we do that how
could we generate a state that
has equal
distributions of amplitude
across across that space uh there's it
yeah I think so I think um
yeah um well I mean first first you can
we can answer like the questions it
cannot be done exactly right because uh
one / square root of five is uh not
generate rotations of you know and then
then I think so there uh there is a
literature on state
preparation um like DEC composing for
example like how you do state
preparation using single Cubit and c not
and slight slightly different methods
than uh for example how you do unit with
single Cubit and c not uh then uh there
is like you
know that for
example uh in this paper right this the
main building block actually is the
state preparation
right so this is this works so basically
uh it sometimes it's actually common to
answer the question how to exactly
prepare states with a certain model
right and uh after that um so I think so
this is kind of included in what what
next right so like um uh but but multi
Cubit for Fibonacci right so actually
how how you exactly what are exactly
synthesizable states with Fibonacci
model and then you can just like round
off the whole state right and is
actually um no State round off is easier
problems and unity around because you
just uh for example
for even you have like multi Cubit state
right you just have one constraint it
must be normalized to one right so
that's uh and that basically leads to
one Norm equation that we already kind
of well it's already well studied by us
for for this case on the other hand in
in inex there are five and no I suppose
um no so I mean in this case you just
you just take ENT and round off each of
them and you you give yourself some
small freedom in the end which is could
be one small entry right it defines
basically the how how good you
approximate and um and actually for rics
uh well I mean for T Atomic field it's
not actually so we use like fifth root
of unity right so it's like u 10 uh 10
catomic field but it it's actually like
force degree extension right so an
integral basis uh that I'm using here
right you can see it's um here where is
my integral yeah so it's just four
numbers right so basically in terms of
integers it's just four degree of
Freedom it's actually other things that
kind of need that in clier T and in
Fibonacci it's both like force degree
extension and there are only like four
there are only two different uh Force
degree groups right and actually there
like this is a cyclic Force degree group
right so it's like in Fibonacci case
it's um uh Z4 and uh in Clifford like
okay sorry I jumped uh so you can look
at gala group of this extension right
and gal group of uh this extension is um
Z4 and for Cliff for it's client
group yeah
so maybe yeah I think it's uh
considerable in the future right I have
a question about the roundoff procedure
so you explained you do it in twostep
fashion first you round off then you do
exact same yes um but somehow it seems
that the round of algorithm itself
there's there's a kind of a trade space
it could be very efficient but then
maybe the the Precision is not so high
or uh you you seem to S Suggest a norm
equation solver to do round off um I
wonder how that compares to like methods
that Salinger proposed he proposed a
very efficient method no it's equation
just so uh what CER does it just solves
special case of Norm equation right so
this is um I mean this is kind of uh
well not quite right he he has a pol you
mean you mean the second second you mean
like so okay if we talking about CER
paper now right so there are two steps
still two steps first step is roundoff
and the second one is uh uh to solve
check if this instance of the norm like
I mean in that paper there is no like
word Norm equation right and uh the
first time when it's appeared like that
it's related to normal equation is that
like practical approximation paper in
that paper there is um uh know this word
and but you know if you talk about in
this language right so then uh First
Step you do roundoff and the Second Step
uh you solve Norm equation and basically
check if it's an easy instance of the
norm equation and so for the best if you
get lucky then it's very fast yeah check
and actually I mean you can you know I I
I said before that I I here I present
this very kind of simple case of what is
an easy instance right but you can say
okay I have for example this I can have
an easy instance of the other type I
have I can have a smooth number right
with just one big prime factor right and
this is also an easy instance for
factoring problem and it will handle
like more situations than just hoping
for having one prime number right and
going back to this roundoff right it's
um actually so this is an interesting
difference between Clifford and T case
and for example Fibonacci case that um
um to bring up a slide where there is
there is this greater than zero the two
greater than zero conditions yeah so
it's
um
back okay this one so so here right here
I get them from round so they actually I
don't need to do any work to satisfy
both of them because um uh first one
satisfied just by choice a number of
this that it's inside here and the
second one is that I can prove that it
will be also satisfied
right so and in Clifford G case it's
actually non automatically satisfied
right and you need to do extra work and
if you remember there's like in saler
paper he has this like volume right it
has the small cells and they there is a
um um bound on the volume it's actually
I think interesting it's might be
related to uh the famous manovski
theorum on uh um about you know convex
bodies and ltis so if there is a like if
you have convex body great with deter
with volume greater than determinant of
the ltis then you can find a point
inside it so and actually it's uh I mean
to me it looks pretty similar uh what he
is doing to the constructive proof of
the minkovski theorem but I mean it's
kind of tweaked a little bit and I've
been looking recently on some literature
and it might be actually you know you
are absolutely right but the bottom line
is that in in htk it's it's very hard
work to actually get a green point in in
a convex domain of
entrance here here here you don't have
to care about the Textra condition the
same as in the case in the v basis case
uh yeah uh
well even
simpler I mean BAS three wheel squared
kind thing wait wait mathematically or
he's making a joke I don't I'm just
a let's thank Vinnie again
okay